[Music]
what's up guys i'm kbhd here and welcome
to september welcome to the ask mcbhd q
a series so this is the middle of what i
would call hardware season or smartphone
season where
pretty much everyone is in the midst of
getting their stuff announced or
released or ready before the holiday
season this is always that busy time of
year it's keeping us very busy around
here but of course we can't leave out
the q and a's so i asked you guys what
you wanted to know on twitter and these
are some of your best questions so
what's the coolest shot you've taken
with the robot
okay so that would easily by far be the
shot that we actually took while we were
at motorized precision and we did that
sort of an orbit intro shot talking to
the robot as it was moving around not
only did it look really cool but with
all the timing and all the words being
said and the sinking of the movement of
the robot with the words
that was actually probably the most
ambitious thing that we've done with the
robot that being said
this is mia
say hi
and if you've noticed some shots in the
past couple videos they've been a little
bit more trippy a little more
interesting she's why
moving on do you think the pixel 3 can
get the best score in dxomark without
having a zoom lens because the zoom
category is important to dxomark yeah i
fully do not expect pixel 3 to have a
second lens again as we've seen from
leaks and i also don't expect it to get
the highest dxo score you're 100 right
one of the biggest new categories of the
dxomark score is the quality of your
zoom so if you have an additional lens
to do optical zoom you will do better
just because of physics in fact i think
i saw recently there was a leaked or
basically it could easily have been
faked but like atop new phones of 2019
dxomark scores and whether it's real or
not even though it's probably not those
scores are very predictable and line up
with pretty much exactly what you'd
expect we're expecting a couple more
triple camera phones to be coming out
soon and uh those will score high on
synthetic benchmarks that take advantage
of those doesn't necessarily mean it's a
better camera though keep that in mind
as a youtuber would you rather have
one video with a billion views or 1 000
videos with a million each so i guess
that adds up to a billion that's
actually really interesting as a
youtuber obviously
the the longevity of a channel having a
thousand videos
all with a million views would be that
would be insane that would be like a
career basically
then again there are not that many
videos with a billion views and pretty
much all of them are music videos so
there's definitely no tech videos with a
billion views there's probably no tech
videos with a hundred million views to
be honest i think probably since ben
gate nothing's gotten anywhere near 100
million views on a tech video so i guess
as someone in my position i'd probably
be more interested in
what kind of tech video could possibly
get anywhere near a billion views
and i'd love to see that but that's of
course a stretch it's 2018 why is apple
still sticking with
four gigabytes of ram you know this is
one of those things that we seem to
forget about every year uh specs
don't mean that much relative to the way
the phone works like pretty much every
new flagship coming out has
somewhat near identical specs very close
if it's a new iphone it has the a12
bionic it has some ram it's got a screen
it's got a camera it's got all these
things if it's a new android phone it's
gonna have snapdragon 845 it's gonna
have four six or eight gigs of ram it's
gonna have a screen it's gonna have a
battery camera etc but every year we
kind of get sucked up into comparing the
specs of iphones with the specs of
android phones this is a really easy
mistake to make because it's just a
number to a number i see four gigs of
ram on one phone and eight gigs of ram
on another phone why does apple still
have four well with their vertical
integration and their optimization and
the fact that they control everything in
there with their walled garden apple
happens to not need eight gigs of ram we
saw this with cpu cores before there was
all these four cores six core eight core
cpus and then there would be new iphone
i would have a four core cpu and you'd
wonder why is apple lagging behind but
when you actually use the phone
just because it has four cores and four
gigs of ram it's not slow that even
reminds me of this iphone 10r everyone's
talking about the iphone 10r and the
numbers on paper and the the fact that
the specs are kind of weak and it has
this sub 1080p display and it only has
three gigs of ram and all these things
are true but the fact is the typical
iphone buyer
first of all probably couldn't tell you
the resolution of their iphone and also
probably doesn't care but i just keep
seeing this every time a new iphone
comes out we latch onto the numbers and
it's easy clickbait to just talk about
how the numbers don't seem to add up but
until you actually use the phone which
nobody has even i i've gotten an hour or
two with it i made a whole video about
it but we haven't really used the phone
yet so until we use the phone we should
probably reserve judgment about just the
numbers and see if it actually seems to
work well so in the case of the 720p ish
display on the iphone 10r it's really
really easy to just say hey it's 2018
720p
bad
maybe it is but let's get it in hand
let's actually see how it looks i can
tell you from the couple minutes i spent
with it it looked pretty good to me but
again we'll have to literally see first
it was the ipod
then the iphone then the ipad then let's
say the apple watch what's next i'm
gonna go with air power
100
it's definitely air power i'm loving the
new autofocus series thank you i'm glad
you enjoyed those videos and the videos
were great now what comes next which car
is next
that is a great question so we started
those auto focus videos with the tesla
model 3 then we went straight to
lamborghini aventador and then we went
to acura nsx the common theme with these
is that they're all tech centered in
some way but as far as what car is next
we there's no plan honestly there's no
slate of cars lined up there's things
that we want to review and that i want
to get my hands on and talk about um but
it's just kind of playing it by ear
maybe porsche will come out with that
missionee pretty soon and we'll be able
to get our hands on it maybe jaguar will
come through with that eye pace maybe
something else electric or tech heavy
will just show up out of the blue like a
faraday future or something like that i
don't really know
but that's kind of the way the autofocus
series works is when it happens we'll
kind of pounce on it maybe you have a
suggestion maybe there's a car that's
out right now that you want to see on
autofocus maybe you want to leave that
in the comment below let me know oh
whatever happened to that bixby speaker
are you planning to make a full review
yes in fact for those of you who missed
it i did on april fool's day as sort of
a parody because we had all these smart
speakers coming out we have the alexa
the google home the homepod what if
bixby had a smart speaker and i made
this entire joke of a video destroying
the concept of a bixby speaker and how
lame and horrible that would be hey
bixby what do you think of siri
and then what do you know at samsung
unpacked a couple months later boom
bixby speaker it's not called the bixby
speaker but it's a smart speaker that
only has bixby this i cannot wait to use
but it doesn't come out for a couple
more months so you know whenever that
happens i'll get my hands on it somehow
i'll buy it i'll find one samsung
probably doesn't want me to have one but
i'll get one and i will review it count
on it so dunkin donuts recently
rebranded to dunkin i did see that what
smartphone company do you think needs a
rebrand i actually thought about this
like
i studied
business and marketing in college like i
didn't think i would be that into brands
and brand image and what that does to
people
i was one of those people who thought
like ads don't affect me but brands
really do affect you a lot and so
changing a brand image or rebranding or
even adding a brand can have a massive
effect on the way people perceive
something like car companies do it all
the time like in the us there's a pretty
mid-tier pretty budget-friendly car
company called hyundai you never buy a
hyundai for the luxury it's because it's
a good price and it's practical but then
the same company wanted to get into
making luxury cars and you know if you
put a hyundai logo on it they just won't
see it the same way as a mercedes or a
cadillac they got the name behind it so
they started an entirely new brand
called genesis they don't have the
hyundai logo or name anywhere on any
genesis car but they make these nice
classy luxury cars now and they have a
totally different new brand name they
will never associate the two together
but that's how you do it so as far as
smartphone companies i could take
advantage of this the one that came to
mind was huawei
and maybe even some others because you
know huawei in the us especially with
the authorities and the headlines and
the things that people talk about with
huawei
it's not going to go well if you try to
sell a huawei phone in the us at this
point there's just a name that's just
not quite lining up with the apples and
the samsungs of the world so maybe
just maybe you got to start a new sort
of new sort of brand name to sort of
start over and get a fresh start in the
u.s we just saw the pocophone too that's
a xiaomi phone it's not called the
xiaomi pocophone f1 as much as it's just
called the pocophone f1 that's for a
reason if you could revive and refresh
any piece of tech what would it be and
why
you could revive
and refresh any piece of tech
what would it be
small phones
small phones bring back the small phones
the smallest
flagship phone you can buy
right now
is like bigger than all of the biggest
flagship phones you could buy eight
years ago bring back the small flagships
tell the story of your hand and the
stitches okay so this is probably new to
some people like i did that iphone
unboxing video and i guess i haven't
shown my hands on camera in a while
people are like what what happened to
your hand that looks like it hurt what's
with the stitches so a couple years ago
in college i broke my hand playing
ultimate
i got a plate and screws in there
they're still in there got the stitches
eight stitches got them all out that's
good then this other scar on my knuckle
is also from ultimate from just like
running and jumping and when i jumped up
my hand hit someone's tooth and then
that was pretty deep but that was no
stitches and then this other one over
here that i had my band-aid on for that
supercar video that was just a
self-inflicted knife wound
way less cool of a story
also eight stitches
and now that's done too can you reveal
the k in mkbhd
what it stands for at 7 million
subscribers
[Music]
how about
10. how about 10. if we add a digit
i'll tell you how about that
all right
i'll end it there thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
you